Vsauce Kevin here 27 years before
Superman flew in to save the day with
alien powers Nikola tope had Bionic
abilities first published in 1911 and
considered one of the first superheroes
Mike Lata had an artificial heart and
night-vision color shifting eyes he was
a cyborg 50 years before that word even
existed in the September 1960 issue of
astronautics
Manfred Clyne's and Nathan Kline first
used the word cyborg to describe a
cybernetic organism their motivation was
to propose a conceptual revolution
instead of building artificial
environments to survive in
extraterrestrial locations why not
upgrade our bodies on earth to adapt to
what we find through space exploration
after half a century of research we may
not be ready to walk around Mars in our
underwear but there are cyborgs among us
and millions more are on the way
mind-controlled robotic arms are a
reality they work by remapping the nerve
endings that control the hand wrist
elbow and shoulder to existing muscle
groups and then programming a prosthetic
limb to react to the input we're years
away from ordering bionic limbs off
Amazon but a bionic eye is commercially
available The Argus 2 named after a
Greek mythological giant with a hundred
eyes is a retinal prosthesis system that
restores some sight to the blind it
features a video camera attached to
glasses that send images as electrical
signals which are processed and
delivered wirelessly to electrodes
implanted on the retina patients go from
complete darkness without it to seeing
flashes of light which allows them to
navigate their home cross streets or in
the case of Larry Hester see his wife
for the first time in 33 years more
common mechanical systems that help
restore lost biological functions
include pacemakers which help control
abnormal heart rhythms and cochlear
implants which are essentially Bionic
ears that deliver signals directly to
nerve fibers so the brain can process
that
as sound but the world's first
government recognized cyborg is Neil
Harbison who has an antenna on his head
that allows him to hear colors he was
born only able to see in grayscale so he
had an antenna integrated within the
occipital bone of his skull that picks
up colors with a sensor and translates
them to sounds that he hears through
bone conduction Harbison successfully
petitioned the British government to
recognize the Eyeborg as part of his
body and was allowed to include it in
his passport photo these are all
technologies we have today currently in
development is an injectable neural lace
that could lead to connecting our brains
wirelessly to the Internet and the
observation of neurons in the medial
temporal lobe that drive the formation
of memories which means that someday we
could literally download knowledge while
we can 3d bioprinting skin synthetic
skin to shield us from cosmic radiation
is a ways off let alone artificial lungs
to breathe Martian air that's 96 percent
carbon dioxide but with continued
progress on small blood pumping motors
designed to replace human hearts and
biohackers having developed eyedrops
that temporarily gave humans night
vision Michael atoll could be roaming
the streets any day now
and as always thanks for watching
[Applause]